hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action unleashes uh yesterday we
played a nice game so today hopefully we
can do uh we can do the same even though
I had two chances that I didn't take uh
we we never got into any serious trouble
uh so uh let's uh create a game 10
minutes per player and uh see what uh
what happens we are currently at
2259 looking forward to to reaching 2300
at some point uh we'll see how long it
takes us to get there and and um okay so
we quickly get an opponent our opponent
is Mr Sub subash Nila uh and we get the
white pieces did we get the white pieces
in the previous game as
well
uh yeah I don't know uh we're going to
go for Bishop to C4 and our opponent
will probably go for Bishop to C5 so uh
it's early morning and I am uh greeted
by an opportunity to play the Evans
Gambit right from the start so we're
going to we're going to go after it at
the to see okay so Bishop to C5 uh to my
knowledge somewhat inferior than Bishop
to A5 or Bishop to E7 but um uh it can
be played of course uh uh yeah okay I I
I probably shouldn't capture it on on D4
but I'm going to play with King to F1 uh
yeah you should not capture that point
you should just uh play play something
else like just develop I automatically
recaptured for no good
reason and I I shouldn't play to F1 but
as I as I misplayed it I'm sort of uh
trying
to uh trying to make it a bit unpleasant
for him all right so how do we go for
this all right so we're going to we're
going to put pressure on F7 right away
since he allows
it um yeah I'm guessing this isn't
really
best okay so he gives back um he gives
back some material in order to if he C
rap go Knight A5 I imagine uh but still
that's not
really yeah that shouldn't
work yeah I mean okay he can do it like
captures Knight A5 checks C6 I capture
again on C6 he actually can play bc6 uh
yeah so it's perfectly
fine uh and if captur so what his plan
is Bishop to E6
okay I can I can live with that I can
live with Bishop to
E6
um is there Queen
B7 yeah we should definitely consider it
but no I don't think there is is I don't
think there is so yeah we just take here
twice captures captures captures he
might take on
D4 yeah that's
possible oh no we're just going to
take we're just going to uh take and
develop something like Bishop to Bishop
to B2 even yeah Bishop to B2 looks
nice and have him worry about his D6
pawn and also some D5 pushes with with
Bishop captures on
G7 so yeah I don't know looks
okay really does does feel like like an
early morning
game so it's funny because I play the EV
Gambit and I'm not down in material
because of that silly recapture on
D4 uh and on yeah okay so he he just
develops as he
should
um he's offering another Pawn it's a
free Pawn so I'm not going to I'm not
going to say
no yeah def definitely not saying no to
to a free E6
pawn and now he wants to trade so we
could trade we could not trade I mean
there's no reason not to
trade uh so we're just going to
trade yeah probably best is to trade can
even
be ah okay so he he will play like
that so we can even grab more space here
make his Knight really
weird okay is there Knight C2
I don't think
so I don't think there's Knight
C2 there's definitely
knight5 yeah knight5 to be to be
somewhat
annoying if he goes here we'll just pick
up the rook and if he goes back we'll
just play Knight to C2 Defender E4 pawn
and make Knight to C2 not really a
threat
um yeah I'm I'm I'm guessing this is the
way to do
it and if we can get F3 in and something
like King T2 yeah we should be perfectly
fine just enjoying our extra
Pawn
uh he does have Knight D3 although it
doesn't do all that
much okay what's what's Bishop
D6 I'm going to play King
E2 just to stop this Knight to D3
infiltration yeah I don't know what
Bishop to D6 is I mean it's a nice
Square for the B Bop but
uh yeah I mean probably we could also
even go just
F4 uh if I if I don't want to slow play
with F3 uh but be you know there are two
knights in front of my king probably
it's best to to keep the pawn structure
solid and then to improve the uh improve
my pieces and then we're going to decide
where where to go from there
okay so okay let's play
F3 no need to rush
anything we probably try some sort of a
breakthrough with
C6 at some point not right
away as then A3 might be a
problem okay so he wants to go for F4
okay so we're going to have to play G3
as well makes sense do we have any
tricky moves here no we don't okay so G3
F4 will will happen at some
point okay so he's really really
struggling here to to get something for
uh for me being up a pawn but there just
isn't anything that's the
problem yeah we can even we can even
bring the Rook
here uh we could also play this Rook
here but then he kind of grabs the
pawn and if I chase away the Knight
which of course I can
do that's not not the
best um yeah let's just bring this Rook
here yeah I could play a little bit
faster he is up on time but uh as
there's really nothing to worry about
here I don't think yeah we'll even stop
uh any H4 and G5
ideas uh G3 is a weakness now but I'm
not uh moving my knight from E5
so but that's fine oh yeah Al he he
blundered Knight G6 yeah he blundered
this and I didn't take advantage of it I
was uh too too quick to stop this see
that's what happens when you try to try
to play faster you don't think about the
space left behind Okay so he blunders it
again now I will take
it
um it even comes with check and then we
grab more
material or no E5 Rook E8 yeah I don't
want
to I don't want to just run into stuff
here but no okay he doesn't really have
anything but yeah let's not let's not
give him anything let's not give him
anything even
better now the Knight is out of
squares okay so of course he will try to
get something for his for his
knight uh but now he's just down too
much
material and okay we still have to be a
little bit careful but uh um I don't
think there's all that much that he can
even try
here yeah it's just being he he's just
down a full Rook
um so he he will try but it is it is
pointless and as usual whenever I say
that I blunder something but here I'm
I'm I'm guessing the position is uh so
much better that there's nothing to to
even if I played the worst move on the
board there's nothing I could blunder
here there's no way for him to to break
through anywhere okay so what's what's
the Rook trying all right let's activate
both of our Rooks not just one since we
are up a rook it would make sense to
activate both of
them yeah I'll probably C6 if he moves
I'm just going to yeah no okay so even
that yeah we can just take
here uh yeah okay Knight C4 or is that
anything yeah it kind of is it kind of
is yeah let's not allow even
that all
right all right let's go after the the
Knight
here after Knight C4 we have Bishop C5
there we
go and if Rook D7 we take the Knight all
right so that's not going to work and if
he goes Rook
here yeah
nothing not much to look forward to all
right so it was a pretty pretty bad game
uh okay so he will give up the
pawn pretty bad game
but I think this is the first time I
actually played C captur on D4 for in
the
Evans I don't think I've ever tried
that okay so what's the what's the
cleanest way here it's a free Pawn so
let's take
it okay it's a free rook let's take that
as
well okay uh my opponent left the game
uh without resigning so maybe he'll come
back but probably he will
not so we're just going to have to wait
for 30 seconds before we can claim the
victory yeah so uh play playing all Rage
Quit it's the
best uh but yeah uh I don't know it's uh
uh it's probably due to me recording
this game that I played the C captures
on D4 which is no way to play the Evans
Gambit uh you know not by a long shot uh
but he immediately went back with Bishop
D7 and it was just very very hard to
play from there uh I wouldn't I don't
usually claim victory I usually wait for
my opponent either come back or I or I
call a draw but here I'm just up uh well
I'm just up two Rooks so I will claim
the victory uh we do get some rating
points and let's just quickly see uh
what happened there and you guys said
that you want me uh that you do not see
the evaluation
bar uh yeah but it is here okay so you
want to see more of the evaluation bar
is that what you're
saying all right I will I will move my
camera a little bit all right let's
uh just check oh no it wasn't even
there okay but I I will move it a little
bit just to see where this uh is sorry
about
that where are you Mr engine oh there's
the engine
okay
okay so the the bar is this thick so you
will you will get to see
it okay there we go and we can even no
this is not here yeah we can even put it
above
this there we go all right so you will
see the bar now during analysis as this
is what you guys requested all right so
E4 E5 Knight F3 uh Bishop to C4 Bishop
C5 B4 D Evans Gambit
uh you can see that the the engine
slightly prefers black here but that's
nonsense never listen to the engine
there play C3 Bishop C5 captures and I
captured back and although yeah okay it
is the sort of the strongest move
recommended by the engine uh I've never
actually play that yeah Bishop here I
played King F1 uh okay the engine says
Knight D2 but even with King to F1 it's
still like zero 0.1 for uh for black so
nothing again nothing spectacular uh B
back
D7 still a move probably Knight F5 is
best here yeah just stopping all of all
of Queen to B3 nonsense but yeah after
Bishop to E7 play Queen B3 and yeah now
uh he should go Knight A5 that's the way
this is
played uh Knight to A5 I capture on F7
he goes King to f8 I move the queen
attack the Knight he captures the bishop
I capture the Knight and I mean if you
want to play like this you can uh but uh
even if you don't it's the best you have
but after D5 yeah Bishop captures is
just not uh not that impressive yeah I
played captures Knight to C3 sort of
better yeah keeping the tension okay I
captured and played Bishop B2 it's fine
Knight F6 I played captures he played
this and I traded okay and now the
position is uh winning for me I just
have to you know remain calm and enjoy
my my extra Pawn he went Bishop D6 King
E2 yeah nothing yeah G3 three
everything okay here H5 yeah I missed
the fork uh but even with H4 it's still
completely winning for me and then he
misses the fork again yeah very ve very
weird stuff yeah always remember what
Josh whin thought us you know uh the the
square Left Behind whenever your
opponent makes a move you always ask
yourself what is the square that he left
behind while the pawn is on H7 it
controls the G6 Square soon as he played
H5 this is the square he left behind
uh but yeah okay here it's merely a
matter of how you want to how you want
to finish this and then uh he even
blundered some more pawns and in the end
he blundered u a rook yeah nothing yeah
this is plus 11 plus 12 okay so not the
best uh even though yeah I faced the I
faced the bishop to uh Bishop back to C5
line uh so so rarely that uh actually
didn't think C captures on D4 was even
strongest for uh white here but
obviously it is and then after after
this you just play Knight D2 and you
play a nice
game yeah yeah makes sense yeah and then
if Knight F6 then D5 is happening and
then after Knight to E7 you just Castle
black castles and okay it's a game Queen
B3 so nothing uh yeah black obviously
will have to give up the the dark Square
Bishop you will have the advantage of
the bishop pair and uh yeah okay a nice
position uh but yeah stuff you have to
know if if you play the Evans game
Gambit uh I did make a tutorial on the
Evans Gambit and um like I said it's not
it's not often that you meet Bishop to
C5 so but now okay you you capture on D4
and everything is perfectly fine uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it a nice daily uh you know game
played in Rapid time format you as you
guys are enjoying them so much I will
play a a game a day if I manage the time
uh so yeah once again really hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see soon continuing
to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your
day